[music playing]
NARRATOR: Sanliurfa,
Turkey, June, 2017.
Author and researcher
Andrew Collins
travels to the Sanliurfa
Archeology and Mosaic Museum,
just 10 miles from
Gobekli Tepe, to meet
with curator Taha Ozyavuz.
- Taha, I presume.
- Welcome.
Nice to meet you.
NARRATOR: He is there to
get an up close look at one
of the most mysterious
stone structures
on Earth at the ancient site.
I think this is what
we've come to see, here.
Right.
And the fact that we have
three different figures
here, each of different sizes--
what do you think
that represents?
Why do you think that it
was damaged or destroyed
in this way in antiquity?
So somebody came along and
deliberately destroyed it.
NARRATOR: If the stone
column found at Gobekli Tepe
represents a genetic
lineage, just why
were two of the figures
deliberately defaced?
Ancient astronaut theorists
suggest that perhaps it
was an attempt to obscure
the truth about humankind's
other-worldly origins.
DAVID WILCOCK: What's curious
about this totem pole is
that there is essentially
a larger being,
perhaps an
extraterrestrial, that
has its hands around this other
being that isn't exactly human,
but has human-like
characteristics.
Could be a primitive human.
This figure appears
to be giving birth.
And the baby that is emerging
from this mother's womb
is clearly a human
baby with a human face.
This suggests, possibly, that a
breeding experiment took place,
leading to the development
of modern humans
as we now know them.
WILLIAM HENRY: The
interesting thing about this
is that totem poles are like
the repository for information.
It's an encyclopedia.
It's like a time capsule.
And so if we have a genealogical
record in this pillar
at Gobekli Tepe, and we follow
the ultimate extension of it,
and we realize that what
they're possibly telling
us is their ancestors
were non-human.
DAVID CHILDRESS: So
you have to wonder.
The whole idea was to
preserve information
from our
extraterrestrial past so
that future generations
would ultimately decode
the information that's there.
Information, possibly, about
our extraterrestrial creators.